that way pray and that's it I love it
you just knocked over instincts members
here Justin Timberlake and joy at Patoka
we take notice like that Hey
I didn't mean to inside I'm sorry my
friends boy bands there's a whole bunch
of them but admittedly two Titans
towered over the rest o town and BB Mac
just kiddin Backstreet Boys versus NSYNC
it's debatable
I am Pro in sync and I am Pro Backstreet
Boys I'm team NSYNC backstreet's back
actually never left mother I'm / in sync
and I am for the Backstreet Boys and
NSYNC for line I and DSB
for life in sync is the greatest boy
band of all time
NSYNC has one of the greatest
entertainers of our world in their band
also known as Justin Randle Timberlake
and his backup band NSYNC gave us Justin
and Britney that is so huge they were
matching denim outfits a metal forever
be in our brains and heart I thought
that I was personally gonna marry JC and
he was my straight girl crush member and
then I'm gay Justin Timberlake JC chasse
we got Lance Bass we got Chris
Kirkpatrick Joey Fatone do you even know
Bryan's last name I mean Latrell you
know is the only person that you can
compare Justin Timberlake to Michael
Jackson you know who's only pretty you
know who I can compare Nick Carter to
the guy who helped me out with my
groceries at Vaughn's yesterday we got
five i buy we got a little filled up a
we got this [ __ ] think we got no strings
attached [ __ ] going on that video
changed my life how it made me want to
be a puppet we all know that instinct is
one member it's Justin Timberlake
everyone else is glorified backup
dancers Wow okay Wow she what first off
they had the best music videos of that
time period they were on TRL number one
like every day yeah but who did it first
Backstreet Boys
bye-bye-bye might be a top 10 song ever
where are they now
they went bye-bye
in sync stop being a band because Justin
Timberlake left but Backstreet Boys are
a band 1999 TRL I wanted that way music
video dance is all in white from the
second that you saw the boys walking
down the runway in that airport you knew
that you had an iconic music video no I
became gay in that moment the crowd
singing Kevin solo come on I mean like
Kevin who this dude Kevin left he
straight up balanced for five years
without the Backstreet Boys first and
foremost there is no NSYNC Backstreet
Boys are the top-selling boy band of all
time
well that's because they have 875
million album sold well that's because
they have eight no Connecticut only s 3
what are you thinking singers on I think
only had to pour out the reality
incredible and yes we had to do eight
all right so you got mastermind Lou
Pearlman right here looks like Jabba the
Hutt kind of there's a little Pearlman
created in sync once the Backstreet Boys
roadie successful the hit everything God
and then the second yes you say there's
still touring Smash Mouth is playing
dave and buster's down the road we call
an adit or they have more great hits
that can ignite a karaoke room then any
boyband that I could think of I'll
certainly in sync how dare you ma'am I
don't I show you the shape of my heart
and I'm gonna say that NSYNC are just a
bunch of losers what about what about
Howie we go what about Howie
when you talk hair you talk dance moves
you talk songs and you just talk about
sexiness NSYNC for the win that whole
singing in the rain thing with the
shirts getting soaked
that was the Backstreet Boys NSYNC gave
us Justin Timberlake which gave us
Justin and Britney which gave us
matching denim outfits and ramen noodle
hair Backstreet Boys they true band the
true boy bands a band that will live
forever my heart
you've got JT and the rest lower five
backup dancers
I think the thing we can both agree on
is that Backstreet Boys NSYNC still
better than one direction still that
isn't one direction boom